prescription drugs are counterfeit in
her new book dangerous doses this talk
is 50 minutes good evening ladies and
gentlemen welcome to Barnes & Noble
tonight we introduce Catherine eben and
her investigative medical report
dangerous doses how counterfeiters are
contaminating America's drug supply
dangerous doses exposes a drug
counterfeiting ring trail by a team of
investigators and demonstrates the
threat to America's drug supply thus
endangering the lives of people relying
on it catherine has worked for the New
York Times New York New York observant
and ABC News and has contributed
articles to the nation The New Republic
The New Yorker and other periodicals
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Catherine even and dangerous doses thank
you all very much for coming it's a
pleasure to see you all I'm going to
begin to read right away but let me
start by saying it just a few words in
2002 counterfeit cancer medicine started
circulating throughout the nation's drug
supply and landed in pharmacy and
hospital shelves across the country it
was a mystery as to who had done it how
it had entered the drug supply and how
it could be stopped a number of patients
had reached had received it among them a
woman named Maxine Blount who lived
outside of st. Louis Missouri and let me
start by reading a section about Maxine
Blount
this is from October 2002 Maxine Blount
died on a clear sunny day in October at
age 61 people from all over came to the
funeral overwhelmed by emotion her
brother Max was unable to read a poem
she had requested Maxine was
laid to rest on a verdant hill
overlooking st. Charles her friend from
the casino plate placed a hundred fifty
and twenty five dollar tokens inside the
coffin four months after she died the
world of her husband Edie
seemed barely screwed on straight he
cried often his delicate and watchful
manner intensified at home he sat in the
dark pondering the effect the weaker
medicine may have had on the progress of
her disease her friend patty believed
that with the right medicine her cancer
might have gone into remission The
Counterfeiters whoever they were had
stolen life and time away from her
Maxine's son Bill who for months could
not think of his mother without breaking
down in tears belief The Counterfeiters
had diminished the quality of her life
in that way they had stolen time from
the entire family I lost time he would
say weeping at the memory of her lying
in bed unable to get up II did not know
what to think in the great big kitchen
in Harvester he kept the evidence of
what had happened in the refrigerator
with a rubber band around it on one
occasion a hush fell as he placed it on
the table and everyone leaned forward
while one of the family's lawyers
Gretchen garrison pointed out the nearly
invisible strike throughs in the tiny
zeros of the lot number P Oh Oh two
three eight four printed on the label
the vial was so small that it
disappeared from view beneath Ed's thumb
the tiny numbers were printed in white
lettering on a band of blue along the
side of the label flustered and
disturbed Garrison felt that she was in
some labyrinth trying to put together a
case in which every alley was a blind
one well hardly naive enough to expect
the drug makers and wholesalers to rush
to their aid she was dismayed by their
response to the Blount's lawsuit they
claimed that they had no obligation to
prevent or even to warn patients about
the crimes of unknown third parties
their denials made Garrison angry they
all take the position it's not my
product son-of-a-bitch she declared one
day as she barreled down the highway
from the Blount's home
that's part of the problem in Florida a
team of investigators who call
themselves the Horsemen of the
Apocalypse
learned incidentally about Maxine's
ordeal but their investigation gradually
brought to light the path that her and
other patients medicine had taken one
painstaking fact at a time
dangerous doses began as an article in
Self magazine in March of 2003 and it
might have stayed just as an article not
a book but in investigating the problem
of counterfeit medicine I got on a plane
to Florida and I met with this ragtag
group of investigators and as I later
learned they called themselves the
Horsemen of the Apocalypse
and they wore matching black polo shirts
with horsemen insignia on them they were
really at least at first glance sort of
a bunch of losers
and as I discovered not only were they
battling diverters and traffickers of
bad medicine and counterfeiters but they
were battling their own bureaucracies
they had pretty much every problem that
you could imagine and they had been
brought together haphazardly by a 28
year old prosecutor named Stephanie
Feldman she didn't have much experience
but she had the experience that mattered
she was an insulin dependent diabetic
and the case had begun because of a
small theft of a few vials of cancer
medicine from the refrigerator in a
pharmacy in Jackson Memorial Hospital
Miami's largest public hospital the kid
who stole the medicine agreed to
cooperate and he told Feldman about this
gray market where life-saving medicine
is sold and resold now she knew that if
this medicine was changing hands moving
in car trunks all around in dirty filthy
conditions that it was probably
threatening patient's life so she did
the best she could
she pulled together three
and to pharmacists her lead investigator
was a man named Gary venema a former
narcotics cop who wore Hawaiian shirts
and had a gold sailboat charm around his
neck and he talked ceaselessly he had
never worked a complex investigation
before but they were going to make a go
of it and I'd like to read you a section
when the team first forms the men were
not a natural dream team
they had scant practice and complex
investigations none had worked such a
high-stakes case as a group their work
lives had fallen short of what they had
hoped to accomplish they didn't follow
orders well though they were the types
to stand on principle
they had usually stood alone or fought
battles that would annoy more people
than they would impress except for arias
they were all Cesar arias they were all
over 50 they all followed some version
of the Atkins diet took medicine for
high blood pressure and had to read
documents and restaurant menus at a
distance at 48 arias was fond of saying
the memory is the second thing that goes
but the men also shared other
characteristics not lost on Feldman they
were tenacious if not obsessive they
were old-school investigators more
comfortable sifting through garbage or
documents and following their suspects
silently than using fancy computer
programs or cutting-edge forensics they
also were the ones who came early and
stayed late and none liked spending time
behind a desk uh the other horsemen and
the team Caesar arias he was a
pharmacist and a drug inspector who
drove around in a beaten-up Buick had
tattered khakis on and a stubborn ox
like temperament and he was obsessed
with cleaning up the drug supply gene
Oden 72 also a pharmacist with two
hearing aids frequently on the fritz he
would fool his suspects into divulging
more than they had planned to John Petri
a cop a dedicated marksman with a wall
of trophies but his real gift was forced
surveillance sitting invisibly in his
car for hours if not days at a time and
his
sidekick Randy Jones an intensely
private man with a passion for
photography which he had mostly
practiced by photographing suspects
going in and out of South Florida
condominiums
this was Feldman's team and really on
their own they had never had a day of
luck but as they came together they had
skills that actually complemented each
other and they began to make headway
partly what I look at in the book is how
bad medicine dirty medicine counterfeit
adulterated stolen recycled diverted
medicine began to enter our pharmacies
and hospitals partly was moving through
legitimate licensed wholesale companies
States had approved them they had
checked boxes saying they had no felony
convictions and they were in business to
dispense life-saving pharmaceuticals but
many of them had backroom operations so
just behind the facade or the licensed
shrine as the investigators called it
was their backroom operation and the
next section that I'm going to read is
how the horsemen uncovered one of these
backroom operations and it's at a
warehouse called gem Co medical
international gene Oden arrives to do
what he says is a routine inspection
Oden strolled back to the cool where
well organized warehouse a hive of
activity with workers using forklifts to
hoist pallets of medicine is there any
other warehouse that you use Oden asked
as he poked around examining medicine
bottles that appeared new and clean jose
castillo the president shook his head
this is it are you sure you don't have
another warehouse owed nest as another
inspector Mary Gabriel took notes this
is the only one Castillo insisted
talking pointedly as though Odin were
deaf this adjacent warehouse was the
only one registered with the state and
therefore the only warehouse in which
the company could legally store
pharmaceuticals
I just want to make sure said Odin a
picture of confusion and forgetfulness
that this is the only warehouse I need
to inspect my hearing aids aren't
working too well
fighting against his impatience Castillo
again confirmed that gem Coe had just
this warehouse could you come outside to
my car Odin asked after a few more
minutes there's some papers I need to
give you as Castillo walked grudgingly
toward the car that Odin had
deliberately parked some distance away
the other horsemen drove up in a swirl
of cars arias Jones and venema Michael
Mann also wore their black polo shirts
bearing horses and hooded scythe
wielding figures as Castillo confronted
the men Odin said happily we need the
key to your other warehouse can you get
it
Castillo's face betrayed his
apprehension and discussed what other
warehouse you'd better get it right now
man told him I don't know where the key
is Castillo offered sourly as he headed
back to the office the short distance
appearing interminable key in hand
Castillo trudged across the blazing
parking lot as though walking an asphalt
gangplank he slowly opened the metal
door and the men walked into a stuffy
reception area strewn with trash the
space had a weak air conditioner and was
filled with costly medicine of every
imaginable kind Cypress ax vert immune
Vioxx vide X nor Vere TRIZ aveer
Crixivan virus cept combivir F of ear
Zion calera and zocor bottles of lighter
fluid and old rags sat amid the medicine
as Castillo hovered in the doorway the
inspectors filed into the room behind
the reception area it was a raw airless
filthy warehouse it looked big enough to
house a medium-sized airplane enormous
pallets of medicines stood along the
walls on shelves that reach nearly from
floor to ceiling more Medicine sat on
the floor
amid drifts of garbage and discarded
packing materials many of the boxes bore
directions clearly stamped on the
outside
store the medicine between 35 to 77
degrees Fahrenheit and protect it from
light but the warehouse was hot at least
90 degrees some of the horsemen
estimated where did all this product
come from pal and where are all the
documents for it venema asked Castillo
Castillo whose olive complexion looked
unnaturally pale pale explained that he
didn't know how the products had ended
up in this warehouse the horsemen had to
secure this mountain of Medicine all of
it technically adulterated they counted
and sorted for hours in the humid filthy
space Odin stood on a pallet of boxes to
direct the work arias reviewed the
sorting his bifocals propped unto his
forehead and venema wandered through the
maze of Medicine offering wild and
profane exclamations the medicine that
the horsemen seize from from Genco
is worth almost three million dollars so
they seize it they take it off the
street but of course there there's more
much more and not only is is the
medicine that they seize adulterated its
outright counterfeit and they discover
counterfeits of almost every imaginable
kind um there had been what's called
diversion which is the illegal sale and
resale of pharmaceuticals for years but
at some point counterfeits began to
enter the system through a network of
homegrown counterfeiters and I'd like to
read just a short section which
describes one of the reasons why that
change took place for years those who
engaged in diversion were able to view
it as a gentleman's crime one got rich
buying and selling medicine that came
with a cover story no matter how feeble
while this secondary market was corrupt
and porous no one outside it was pumping
counterfeit medicine into it that
changed as the drug wars ever harsher
penalties led narcotics traffickers into
pharmaceutical wholesaling which they
found to be more profitable and lower
risk
the Psychopaths got involved and ruined
it for everybody complained mark Novosel
who viewed himself as an old-school
diverter never intending to hurt anyone
the rapidly expanding network of
middlemen the uneven patchwork of state
enforcement and the lack of
comprehensive federal regulations made
it relatively easy to slip convincing
counterfeits into the stream of Commerce
and the wrong people had figured this
out hardcore criminals who already moved
contraband like narcotics and weapons
through underground distribution
networks added pharmaceuticals to their
inventory the new counterfeiters and
traffickers surprised the old diverters
with their remorselessness Jose Gris
ozone brother had died of cancer at age
44 another counterfeiter Eddie Goran who
was arrested by the FDA after attempting
to sell vials of Miami tapwater
relabeled as Procrit was himself an
insulin dependent diabetic during one
conversation with an undercover agent
his associate rationalized their scheme
by explaining that the patients taking
their medicine were going to die anyway
the medicine in question much of it is
life-saving and much of it is
extraordinarily expensive and in one of
the principal schemes that I described
in the book a counterfeit er an alleged
counterfeiter named Jose griot took tiny
vials of low-dose Procrit and he had
counterfeit labels made that were 20
times the strength and much greater in
price and he had them glued on to the
tiny little Procrit labels and even
Amgen's own packaging specialists could
not tell the difference between the
actual Procrit and Gris oz counterfeit
Procrit the the the horsemen quickly
focused on a man named Michael Carlo a
medicine trafficker who is selling stole
diverted counterfeit medicine out of hit
the laundry room of his mansion in
Weston Florida four years previously he
had filed for bankruptcy and he in four
years earned back over four million
dollars total take-home profit bought a
stable of sports cars yachts and he
becomes very quickly their central
target but in order to make a case
against him a racketeering case they
begin to target his associates and they
zero in fairly quickly on a group of men
called his cooks and what they do is
they cook up medicine for him they find
it anywhere they can they steal it from
warehouses they buy it from Medicaid
patients and they bring it in cardboard
boxes in a big jumble to his house
having removed to the patient dispensing
labels one of those fellows is a guy
named David Ebanks and I will read you a
section about there the Horseman's
efforts to make Ebanks cooperate in
April the winding maze of pedigree
records counterfeit lot numbers and
aliases led the horsemen to another of
Michael Carlos cooks his name was David
Ebanks and on a bright afternoon in
Miami's Liberty City venema arias Petri
Jones and a detective named Steve
Zimmerman surrounded him on a weedy
sidewalk next to an abandoned lot having
just arrested him for using a forged
driver's license to open a bank account
they wanted his cooperation
but Ebanks was sulky and silent dressed
in linen pants and sandals he stood with
his head hanging down and his handcuffs
cinched tight Ebanks was a social worker
with a penchant for prostitutes and fat
cigars the horsemen believed that he
collected and sold medicine for Michael
Carlo using false identities post office
box addresses shell companies and
obscure bank accounts venema decided to
approach the project of his cooperation
the way that he used to work
homicides in Hialeah keep on arresting
Ebanks jailing him and towing his car
one charge at a time causing so much
disruption to his life that has his
resistance would finally crumble on
arriving venema plucked the business
card of Craig brand Esquire the lawyer
who represented many small secondary
wholesalers from Ebanks his shirt pocket
tell Craig I said hello venema guffawed
the horsemen surfed through he banks his
cellphone and took note of a recent call
to brand Ebanks ventured officer if
you're going to arrest me oh I am
interrupted venema now turning his
attention to Ebanks his wallet so what
have you and Fabian been up to he asked
referring to Fabian Diaz another Carlo
associate Ebanks denied knowing Diaz
even as venema pulled a car insurance
card and Diaz his name from Ebanks his
wallet meanwhile Ebanks his cell phone
rang steadily is business that hopping
asked venema Zimmermann who had the
native gift of the homicide detective an
ability to talk to anything even a rock
until it said I did it answered Ebanks
his phone and began a cordial
conversation with the person on the
other line it was a schizophrenic
patient calling Ebanks from a local
psychiatric ward offering to sell his
medicine zyprexa a costly favorite of
diverters Zimmermann made an appointment
to meet with the patient the next day
exultant venemous sang out roses are red
violets are blue I'm schizophrenic and
so am I
Petri explained to Ebanks that for using
false documents to open a bank account
he could be charged with racketeering in
the future if he didn't cooperate he
banks mumbled you mind if I scratch my
nose he leaned over Zimmerman's car door
and rubbed his nose against the top you
know said venema as though thinking it
over I don't mind ruining your entire
life your handcuffs okay Zimmerman asked
Andy Banks shook his head miserably too
tight good I like it that way said
venema as they loaded Ebanks into the
police car and slammed the door turn up
to here he told Petry jokingly the car
sauna being another tried and true
Hialeah technique as venema watched
Ebanks disappear down the street he
smiled broadly the beauty is they know
he said we know they know they know we
know they know we know they know we know
they know he had made it clear to the
bad guys that he was coming and he did
not want them to forget him anytime soon
as they as they go on this chase after
the bad medicine their investigation
actually takes them to a strip club so
far south in Miami that there's actually
farmland there I can tell you after
several visits to the strip club the
strip club is called playpens south and
the horsemen cultivate an informant in
the strip club who calls himself rocky
he is the daytime manager of the club
the club is open 24 hours a day and
rocky who is a convicted cocaine
trafficker and doesn't want to be in
trouble anymore that's what he says
begins to see medicine arriving in
coolers into the club and leaving in
coolers and being stored in a back room
and so he begins to record in his Palm
Pilot the date of these medicine
exchanges and the following is a scene
that rocky later related to
investigators that he had witnessed I
should say the strip club was co-owned
by a bouncer
and a urologist both of whom are under
criminal indictment now on April 2nd at
around 7 p.m.
luison just met in the playpens backroom
and confronted their first real sign of
trouble a customer of Lewis's was
displeased the man had returned an order
of Procrit claiming that the product was
bad and so Lewis had brought it back to
the strip club where he bought it news
of counterfeit Procrit was spreading and
no one wanted to be caught with it so
now as the bar manager rocky watched
Lewis and just turned off the lights in
the room huddled together and gazed at
the boxes of Medicine beneath an
ultraviolet light behind them two
hundred and nineteen thousand in cash
was stacked on a table the deal of the
evening put on hold as they studied the
details of the packaging some of the
club's employees who were also in the
room could not be sure whether the men
were examining the boxes to detect if
they were counterfeit or to see whether
they were good enough counterfeits to
resell just reassured Lewis that he
would make sure the boxes were better in
the future that night just exulted I
love making a hundred thousand per week
burrito - was said to be netting this
much rocky who had initially thought the
men were selling steroids to muscleheads
also was struck by a phrase the men used
to describe the medicine colored water
the horsemen do not succeed in all of
their goals chief among them which is to
depose the managers of the bureau of
statewide pharmaceutical services but
they do succeed in making significant
number of arrests among them the man who
they suspect of selling of making the
counterfeit Procrit and reselling it so
I want to read that little section I'll
close with that and then take questions
afterwards and because we're being
filmed by c-span
if you could please wait until a
microphone comes to you to ask your
question that would be terrific
in Doral near Miami Jose griot looked
stunned to find himself under arrest at
police headquarters Jack Calvo and Cesar
arias sat him down and explained that
they knew all about the eleven thousand
boxes of Epogen that he had relabeled
and that if they could prove that one
person died from the medicine he would
be charged with first-degree murder the
guy I work for is very upset about this
said Cal var I'd hate to be in your
shoes griot looked horribly upset and
his lower lip began to quiver
he said despondently I'll never get out
thank you very much and I would I would
love to take questions I'll also say we
have in the audience we have a lawyer
here Eric Turco it's Eric if you could
just stand up who is representing a 16
year old boy on Long Island named Tim
Fagan who received counterfeit Epogen
and Congressman Steve Israel who is a
Democrat on Long Island introduced a law
called Tim Fagin's law last Monday which
is legislation that would close some of
the loopholes in the drug supply so if
questions are highly legal I may refer
them to Eric otherwise I will be happy
to take any and all questions
I understand that coincidental we'll
come in with your book coming out a
cardinal health announced that it would
stop dealing in the secondary market
which is the source of this problem can
you tell us anything about the other two
major wholesalers have they done
anything um none of these counterfeits
would be reaching patients were not for
the nation's three largest wholesalers
cardinal health Amyris or sand McKesson
who not only buy medicine directly from
the manufacturers but look for bargains
in the secondary market and the book
documents how some of the bargains they
found from michael carlo and others like
him
that is how counterfeits are entering
the system just the few days before my
book was came out Cardinal Health
announced that it would close its
trading division and no longer by
potentially suspect medicine from the
secondary market that's certainly a good
move and there are several other
companies which probably should do the
same yeah could you explain how these
counterfeits actually get into
drugstores actually get transmitted to
individual patients let's take the the
counterfeiting case of Jose Gris oh he
he had he hired a middleman to order low
dose Epogen and Procrit from a tiny
walk-in pharmacy in Miami that pharmacy
turned around and ordered tons of this
stuff from two major wholesalers
Cardinal and Ameri source they sold the
low dose Epogen to this pharmacy which
then kicked it out the back door did not
dispense it to any patients resold it to
a middleman who resold it to Jose griot
who then had hired a printer to make
counterfeit labels took those
counterfeit labels and the low dose
vials to an out-of-work iron welder in
his trailer
South Miami he soaked the vials
overnight in the back of his trailer
under the broiling Summer Sun put on the
new high dose labels all in all griot up
labeled a hundred and ten thousand vials
which is about enough to treat over
30,000 cancer patients for a month the
entire scheme netted him forty six
million dollars he in turn brought the
medicine to his buyers which included
playpen south the strip club they sold
it to various shell companies which then
sold it to legitimate or licensed
wholesalers and then as it moved through
the wholesale chain a Mara source Bergen
was looking for discounted high-dose EP
Jen in the secondary market they ended
up buying back their own medicine which
had been counterfeited in the interim
they sold that medicine to CVS which
dispensed it to Tim Fagan questions a
lack of a federal system of regulation
could you talk about what the FDA how
the FDA fits into this in 1988 the
problem of diversion or resale of
medicine was so serious that Congress
passed a law called the prescription
drug marketing act and that required
that every buyer and seller of medicine
put their names down on a pedigree paper
this the same you'd have if you buy a
car or you buy a pure-breed dog a
pedigree paper that functioned as an
audit trail the wholesalers lobbyists
stepped in and said that was too
burdensome too difficult and that it
would harm their small businesses and so
the FDA set aside that requirement and
instead it said okay anybody who's an
authorized distributor doesn't have to
pass along a pedigree and what that
meant was that authorized distributors
the
distributers could launder the pedigree
of the drug it could have moved through
12 different hands but as soon as it hit
a marry sources warehouse the pedigree
trail stopped and the medicine was sold
as though clean and that's the problem
right now yeah back there it's a book is
about Miami and Florida and but I
gathered that this is a nationwide thank
congressman Israel is obviously going to
introduce federal legislation and
talking about the FDA as does this stuff
come here to New York too and you know
if anything's going on in terms of law
enforcement in New York or something to
try and help us out here um first let me
say that our drug supply is only as
clean as its dirtiest link the medicine
wherever it may originate is moving
throughout the country because it's
being resold by national distributors so
medicine that was pouring out of Miami
that was counterfeit was moving all
across the country and that's true of
counterfeit medicine that came from
elsewhere there had been a number of
arrests in New York actually there is a
ring of traffickers who were buying lots
of medicine from Medicaid patients at
clinics in New York cleaning the
medicine removing the patient dispensing
labels with lighter fluid and heat guns
and then reselling it to their
associates in Florida and California and
there have been a number of arrests with
more to come yeah it's kind of my image
that pharmacists used to handle the
medicine more personally maybe make
formulations or something and that now
pharmacists are highly trained but in
fact they don't actually use their
skills for very much at all what would
it take to make pharmacists actually
responsible or to give them actually the
tools what would it be mass spec gas
chromatography that they would actually
certify and analyze the material they
give to people which would be
technically relatively easy these days
and certainly easier than the mixing
of the medicine that they did and
certainly something they're technically
qualified to do um well there certainly
are still you sound like you may be a
pharmacist or you know okay
there are still compounding pharmacies
where pharmacists do make their own
formulations that comes with problems
too you may have heard of the highly
publicized case in in Missouri where a
pharmacist named Robert Courtney was
found guilty of having diluted his
patients cancer medicine 98,000
prescriptions over the course of a
decade so that you know having having
pharmacists make their own formulations
does not unfortunately solve the problem
but many people feel that pharmacy
chains should require from their
suppliers a contract saying we're only
going to buy from you if this medicine
has come directly from the manufacturers
they have yet to do that some people
feel that it's because they want the
discounts that come from buying
substandard medicine pharmaceutical
companies bear some responsibility I
mean they have their Lobby yes they
certainly have a lot of clout I mean
they'd be a little more responsible
about passing it on through
Paul sellers pharmacists have known
about excuse me the drug companies have
known about this problem for years and
mostly they have settled lawsuits
confidentially with patients I would say
the problem has become so big and has
gotten so much publicity that there has
been a sea change within Pharma and the
drug companies feel they can no longer
brush this under the rug so they are
actually advocating now this
comprehensive pedigree where the
medicine would be its origin would be
carefully recorded through the supply
chain so where they were once one might
say bad actors I do think that they have
come around to the magnitude of the
problem
that a death of a sick patient is gonna
be from a bad diluted or counterfeit
drug or just from a sick from the cancer
or something that's an excellent
question
FDA officials have stood before Congress
and said that the number of patients who
have died or been harmed by this is
perhaps unknowable the reason is
patients take the medicine and they get
rid of the evidence
they throw away the packaging they throw
away the vials later on an alert may
come out they don't know what lot number
they had all they know perhaps is that
they felt a little funny or their
medicine stopped working in the worst
cases they may die and the evidence is
buried with them and that is why a
number of investigators call this the
perfect crime
how profitable is buying from the
secondary market for these wholesale
companies the big companies hugely
profitable while it's hard to put an
exact number on it
most people estimate in the billions if
playing by the rules
wholesalers operate on a very thin
margin they might get a discount from
the drug makers of about 2% below wack
or the wholesale acquisition cost some
of these diverters and traffickers are
selling their medicine half off 50 below
wack and the medicines no good there are
investigators who say the price tells a
story and everybody in the industry
knows what that story is this is the
dirty little secret of of the drug
industry and just like people knew that
the drug the tobacco companies knew that
smoking would kill you yeah you tell us
how have the five investigators
responded to your book and how have
their lives changed as a result of being
the subject of the book
well Cesar arias was thanked for all his
hard work by being put on suspension
with pay by his Bureau I believe in part
because he spoke with me he had been
highly awarded with integrity awards and
productivity Awards for years he was one
of the first people who sounded a
warning about this problem spent years
going to law enforcement no one would
listen to him finally when the truth
came out he was suspended with pay this
is the problem that the investigators
have faced is that nobody wants to
acknowledge that the system in Florida
as elsewhere totally broke down
Cesar Aires his Bureau was giving
licenses to narcotics traffickers with
felony convictions all they did was hand
them an application that had a box on it
you could check have you ever
been convicted of a felony and if you
check no you could put down $700 and all
you needed was a refrigerator a lock on
the door and some air conditioning and
you were in business doesn't every drug
type have a unique a pill shape and also
a number designating the dosage on that
pill or would they typically re
repackage the pills or something or
grind them down and reform them or
something pills do have identifying
specific identifying features and the
counterfeiters are very good at
replicating them you can buy second-hand
pill making machines on eBay in the case
of counterfeit lipitor and in 2003 there
was a recall of 18 million suspected
counterfeit doses what the
counterfeiters did is they forged a
letter from Pfizer pretending to be a
new division of Pfizer that they were
setting up in Costa Rica and they sent a
letter to the engineering firm saying we
at Pfizer are opening up a new division
please send us the dyes the forms to
make the tablets and they they were in
business it worked perfectly yeah I'm a
veteran so all that pharmaceuticals come
through the Veterans Administration
Hospital is there any danger of the
seeping in to the what would be the
highly protected governmental handling
of pharmacies for its sick veterans
probably everybody here in the audience
can guess what the answer is yes the
Veterans Hospitals buy from the major
wholesalers as does pretty much every
everybody 90% of our medicine moves
through the wholesale system that my
book describes yep I don't know if this
is your if this is your last chapter or
they probably might not be a last
chapter on this but what can the
ordinary consumer and user do is there
anything or are we completely in the
dark
first of all I have a web
site dangerous doses dot-com I also
which lists safety tips that are also in
the back of my book here's what you can
do you need to know what your medicine
looks like and how it's packaged you
have to become familiar with it then if
it changes if there is a change that
looks strange to you you must ask your
pharmacist about it if you take pills
put them in your hand before you swallow
them look at them under the light if you
take injectable medicine make sure it
feels the same going in does it sting or
burn in a different way are you having
strange side effects or does your
medicine suddenly stop working and if
any of those things are the case I would
say first step is talk to your
pharmacist you can also go on the
internet
the FDA keeps a site called MedWatch
which reports alerts about counterfeits
you can call the drug makers what they
will probably say to you is if you
suspect you've gotten counterfeit send
us back all your medicine and we will
send you the good stuff don't do that
you can send the back some of the
medicine but you need to keep some with
you because that's the only evidence you
have that you've taken it I would like
to know if medicines from Canada have
that habit have they crossed the border
into Canada do you know um first of all
medicine from Canada is not always from
Canada or it may be from Canada via
Belarus as has been the case and there
have been a number of highly publicized
cases of that so on the face of it
Canadian medicine is no safer or no more
dangerous but Canadians regulate the
prices of their drugs and the prices are
fixed but in the United States drug
makers sell the same drug for a whole
array of prices to many different people
depending on what kind of volume
discount you get those varying prices
allow middlemen to
arbitrage the price of the drug to buy
low and sell high and it's that
arbitrage that movement in the middle
that opens the doors to counterfeiters
so in theory price regulation like the
kind they have in Canada would make us
safer yeah so at this point is the
United States the only place that this
is happening this this horrible
situation is happening it's there's
counterfeiting endemic all over the
world and the World Health Organization
has estimated that 10% of the nation of
the world's drug supply is counterfeit
in some countries that can reach as high
as 40 percent however by the drug makers
own numbers and for my book I obtained a
confidential study that the drug makers
did of counterfeits in different systems
throughout the world America in 2004
ranked number one in the world for
incidents of counterfeiting diversion
and theft of pharmaceuticals what that
report tells us is that America has
become the go-to market for
counterfeiters because of our high
prices
now most people assume that we pay so
much but it's really safe and in fact it
is the opposite which is that our high
prices have made our medicine very
attractive to the wrong people back
there
the I want to know what happens to the
pharmaceuticals when it hits the
expiration date is there a way they're
they're supposed to be disposed of and
is it enforced yes it's supposed to be
disposed of and no it is not enforced
and one thing that a lot of the
wholesalers will do is buy they'll get
steep discounts for almost out-of-date
medicine and then they'll real able that
so you know this is medicine medicine
that is expired is expired or has lost
its potency is arriving at our
pharmacies with some regularity take go
one more two more questions in the back
there and the customer of CVS I take
some very important drugs how worried do
I need to be now well the rule of thumb
it seems to me is that the more
expensive the medicine the more likely
it is to be counterfeit for the simple
principle that counterfeiters are going
to go after the hundred dollar bill not
the single they have targeted the very
fancy cutting-edge name-brand
biotechnology medicines those are
attractive to counterfeiters but they
also go after the the big-name sellers
like lipitor now I will say that
Congress largely ignored this problem
until there was a massive lipitor
counterfeiting and then because
three-quarters of Congress takes lipitor
they said my god this is a serious
problem and something must be done
I guess perhaps the good news is that
once medicine has been counterfeited
counterfeited and it drug makers do what
they call hardening the target making
that medicine harder to counterfeit the
counterfeiters will move on to other
medicines so if you're taking medicine
that has already been counterfeited you
might be okay yeah back there 10%
probably are counterfeit from that we
can deduct more
how many people are actually damaged if
we just do a simple so the number is
very important to get a specific number
says 100,000 people are dead because of
that that's a lot more potent than
saying unknown well ten percent is the
worldwide number that the World Health
Organization has estimated the FDA
released report saying that they
believed that less than 1% of the
nation's drug supply was counterfeit I
went down there and met with some of the
officials and I said well how do you get
that number how'd you arrive at that
they said well we didn't do any studies
we don't really know we guessed because
we don't want to worry people and we
can't believe that any more of it is
counterfeit so in the book what I did
was take them at their word let's say
less than 1% is counterfeit well 1% is
35 million prescriptions but nobody in
fact knows what the real number is and
no random sampling has been done to
study the number of the counterfeit
drugs are there those who which while
they don't do you any harm may be
harmless do you know what I mean yes
they made they it's like taking water or
something like that rather that's some
kind of poison right some some of the
counterfeit medicine is harmless well
you're not getting better so there's
harm in that way but it's not actively
dangerous but it really depends upon the
counterfeiting scheme in some cases they
were taking insulin and using it to
substitute for aids medicine now if
you're not a diabetic and you're
injecting that and you're already immune
compromised patient can be very very
serious obviously so it really depends
on the counterfeiting scheme take one
last question what do the drug companies
do to counteract the counterfeiting he
said they're just sometimes the
counterfeit was a move on from one drug
to another because the companies have
taken
action against what is that type of the
security at the drug companies works on
several levels they have they embed
covert and then overt security features
into their medicine so covert security
measures might be chemical tags or
markers that they embed in the packaging
or even in the medicine itself overt
security measures might be Holograms
they use color shifting ink like the
feds have just put on the new 20s to
prevent counterfeiting so those are some
of and they change the packaging they
try to change the packaging every six
months or so I've been told that
basically given 12 to 18 months the
counterfeiters can copy anything thank
you very much for coming
Katherine even is author of dangerous
doses how counterfeiters are
contaminating America's drug supply it